let's go next to steph from glasgow
oh wow
welcome
hi
um i just wanted to say
as a person not from america
really i couldn't tell from your accent
you're i thought you were from texas
oh wow
well
um
i just find
the whole gun culture thing insane yeah
it's it baffles me and i've actually
just been saying to myself earlier like
if you
were claiming self-defense would you not
have like here you would just kick the
person and make them
leave you alone like what's that what's
the automatic reaction to like point a
gun and shoot somebody that baffles me
this is exactly what i'm talking about
when i'm saying you know we're looking
at these videos of 20 people walking
around with long guns and all of this
insanity and we're trying to focus in on
this narrow question of like was written
house justified in shooting the people
that he shot
much of the world is having exactly your
reaction which is
how is even the context remotely
considered acceptable in any way at all
that this is even a thing that happens
yep
yeah it's it's just
it's just a totally different culture
and it it's scary because he's just a
kid as well it's
yeah
it's um now are people are people in
scotland talking about this case at all
um
not from
um what i've seen nothing on the news
about it really okay um and nobody that
i talk to really has mentioned that
either so i don't think it's that
like a thing to be honest but i follow
american politics more than people that
i know
so
and like american crime and stuff so
um
uh yeah most people
are really listening i'm
interested in it to be honest
got it got it got it hey quick question
um are you familiar with a um
with uh
uh now i don't even remember what
they're called what do you guys call
sodas you call them
fizzies fizzy something
um
i would say fuzzy juice
fizzy are you saying fizzy or fuzzy
fezzy
oh fizzy juice got it okay and so
is sprite a fizzy juice a what is it
it's a type of fizzy juice yeah
it's fizzy juice yeah like
we also use just like names like i would
just say oh i want like diet coke or
whatever so we just use a name but fizzy
juice is like a an umbrella term it's
your category it's a category like some
people would say this is soda this is
pop this is a fizzy juice
yeah got it yeah fuzzy juice
okay well you really said it all i can't
i can't think of anything else to
mention at this point and thank you for
taking my call i'm like so nervous i
don't know if you can tell you i can't
tell at all you did great
oh thank you yeah all right thank you so
much for the call
no worries all right there we go steph
from glasgow
a very very powerful testimony
let's go next to isaiah
from arkadelphia isaiah you're on the
air
isaiah from arkadelphia you're on the
air
here
you're completely uh digitally modulated
i couldn't understand a word of that
oh um oh boy
yo
are you a robot or is that just a voice
distortion
you're not a robot
oh boy
oh dear god all right unfortunately i am
going to have to let you go just nobody
can hear what's going on there it was uh
interesting but nobody could hear it
let's try amir from washington dc amir
it is your turn
oh god
my god that is just uh now i'm wondering
if it's potentially on my end let's try
bryce from denver bryce please rescue us
wow
how could that possibly be on my end i
don't even know what that what that
could be
and people in the chat say that he's
clear so it's clearly on my end wow
all right well listen
it's on my end but i still can't
understand a word anybody's saying let
me very quickly try to disconnect and
then reconnect let's just let's just try
again i'm going to go back to amir from
dc let's see if that fixed it
right
right yeah no it's uh
if people could hear what i'm hearing
well listen i think we're just gonna
have to let me try one more just to see
it may be on my maybe it is on my